(studio audience cheering)
- All right.
- Hello, hello.
- They love you.
They love you.
Oh my God.
Well, welcome back to the show.
This time we came to you.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- So much for coming to New York.
- You didn't have to travel far.
- No, it's the A train.
I took the A train to 59th Street.
- I know.
- It was great.
- That's why- I've been
here for like a month.
I love the subway.
My kids love it too.
They think it's so cool that
they hate getting in cars now.
And I'm like, sometimes
it's nice to get in a car,
but like they love the subway.
So wait, I heard that
you took your son's class
on a field trip.
I'm about to do a field
trip with my daughter.
- I did.
My, my son's class was
obsessed with Greek myths,
and this whole second grade class.
Greek myths and Greek heroes.
And so I took them to go
see "Hadestown" on Broadway.
Yeah, there we are.
(studio audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's so cool.
- And it was, it was me,
and 26 second graders and their parents.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Which was fun.
We really, it was it was a loud matinee,
for the cast of "Hadestown."
- So was your family involved
with your school projects
when you were a kid?
- Yes
- [Kelly] Do you, do you
get involved with your kids?
- Yes, I did.
We, my son and I actually made a video
for my wife's 40th birthday.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And he wrote the whole thing
and I edited it with my
friend, Alex Horowitz.
But yeah.
- Yeah.
- But my parents totally, like I did a,
I remember doing a video book report
of "The Pushcart War" in third grade.
And my grandmothers in it,
my great-grandmothers in it.
They all played teachers.
- [Kelly] What?
- And my mom was in it,
and I made them act out
scenes from the book,
and filmed it with like a huge camcorder.
- I love forced family fun.
Yeah.
(studio audience laughing)
It's awesome.
We actually have this
video, so let's see a bit.
- [Lin-Manuel] Fantastic.
- The teachers need tax for the classes.
For your convenient, we have hired people
to play the role of teachers on strike.
- [Teachers] No tax!
(teachers chanting)
- [Lin-Manuel] What is
the meaning of this?
- [Teacher 1] Mr. Mayor,
we don't think it's fair
that you be taxing our tax, the tax.
We not breaking the tires on your truck.
You should find out who's
responsible for that,
and make them pay.
Not us poor citizens who
have to teach in schools.
And now we have to spend our money to buy,
to pay extra tax on tax, no tax.
(teachers chanting)
- Oh my God.
(studio audience cheering)
- Tour de force performance.
- Your mother, I see where
you get your passion.
- My mom was so committed to,
you can tell I'm genuinely
scared of that video.
(Kelly laughing)
I knew what was happening.
I told her what to say to me.
But then she gave it such ferocity.
- She is, I see where you get it from.
- Yeah, I'm like against the wall
with my little mayor's hat.
- [Kelly] I love it.
She was full on yelling
at you on, but wait.
So today marks the start
of Hispanic Heritage Month.
So what does this month
mean to you, specifically?
- Well, I, I think for
me and for all of us,
it's a great way to showcase the diversity
that is the Latino experience.
It's, you know, we're not one country.
We come in, all colors, and
all shapes, and all sizes.
And we're 30 some odd countries.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's about sharing
what makes us distinct.
And also like all the
many things we share.
- It's great for us too,
that aren't of that culture.
But we get to experience
it because of this month.
- [Lin-Manuel] Yeah.
- We get to see stuff that
maybe we wouldn't have known
and learn stuff.
So I, it's important for everyone.
So with "Encanto", you
celebrated the Hispanic family,
and generational trauma
was kind of a major theme.
- Yeah.
Well, it's funny.
I remember talking to you,
I think the week before it came out
- Dude, I love you so much.
You're so talented.
I don't, I don't think,
you know a person that
seen that movie more
than myself because of my kids.
- Well, I remember,
I remember the week
before it came out also,
I did your show and I met
someone and his name was Bruno.
(Kelly laughing)
And I said, you're not
gonna understand this,
(Kelly laughing)
(studio audience laughing)
but I'm so sorry.
I'm just, I'm just remember I
said, I'm sorry, in advance.
- [Kelly] It's like any girl named Jolene.
- Yeah, Jolene or Bruno.
Eliza's, I am sorry.
- Yeah.
I love that, that's hysterical, but,
but speaking of "Encanto,"
is it true that Bruno
originally had a different name?
- Yeah.
Bruno in the early drafts was named Oscar.
- [Kelly] I can't hear that now.
- Yeah, well.
(Kelly singing)
♪ You don't know about Oscar ♪
- Oscar, Kirk, Kirk, Kirk.
Yeah, it doesn't sing.
- [Kelly] Yeah, Bruno sounds-
- Yeah, and then they found
out that Oscar Madrigal
was like a super common name,
or like a taken name in Colombia.
And so they, they gave me
like three other finalists.
And as soon as I saw
Bruno, I was like, got it.
- Yeah.
- I got the whole song.
- I got Bruno and I can
play with the no, no, no.
And I'm done.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Thank you for writing this song for me.
- [Kelly] Great vowel.
Is a great vow to sing, really.
Yeah, I like to change those up sometimes,
and they're like that's
not how you pronounce it.
I don't care.
All right.
So you have a new movie coming out
and it's about two Mexican-American boys.
And can you tell us about it?
- Yeah, absolutely.
This is this was this beautiful
young adult novel called
"Aristotle and Dante Discover
the Secrets of the Universe."
And I was lucky enough
to be the actor hired
to recite the audio book years ago.
- Oh wow, yeah.
- It's a beautiful coming of age story,
about these two Mexican
teenagers, Aristotle and Dante.
The filmmaker, H. Alberto
had an amazing screenplay,
and she had a vision to,
to put it up on screen.
And I, I realized like, oh,
my job is to help you get this made.
So I'm a producer on the movie.
- Yeah.
- It's a beautiful movie and
it'll come out next year,
just premiered at the
Toronto film festival
and it'll be out soon.